happy thursday everybody man it's cold
outside i want to share a beautiful
picture uh from valley of fire and
because i think the weekend is just
going to be fantastic for getting out
and about i want to thank herbert engner
for sending this this was from a couple
of weeks ago when we had some clouds in
the sky but gosh there's a gorgeous uh
scenery up there they're in the 20s up a
valley of fire this morning if you have
some great photos that you'd like to
share with us weather photos send them
to pixpix 8newsnow.com
yes it is cold the moapa valley is in
the 20s this morning we've got 30s and
below freezing this morning in las vegas
that's because the winds really calmed
down overnight and that cold air settled
in we're in the 20s in seven hills
mountain's edge has dropped to 26 and 29
in summerlin right now so hopefully
you've got your sprinklers turned off if
today is your watering day you've got
the pets indoors and those exposed pipes
are wrapped as well as those delicate
plants winter is not over folks we still
have about seven more weeks to go of
winter 21 out at red rock with a little
bit of a breeze and kyle canyon is 20
only because the winds picked up a
little bit but it feels like it's about
12 degrees up there and it feels right
now like it's in the 30s in laughlin
because they've got winds going on the
river as well so you know laughlin it
feels colder than it looks 20s in
mesquite
19 right now at indian springs 26 in
prep and single digits in ely and cedar
city yeah that cold air has settled in
for sure on the west coast things are
pretty clear but up in seattle now
they're already starting to get a little
taste of some more rain and snow on the
way look at the intermountain west
denver's at four in the rockies this
minus four excuse me and temps below
zero in the northern plains all that
cold air in the midwest and the central
plains associated with that big winter
storm ahead of the cold front very warm
mild air that's where the rain is but on
the backside of that cold front it's
snow and on the dividing line it's
freezing rain and ice let's roll the
future cast so many areas as bianca was
saying paralyzed with road and air
travel because of this winter storm by
tomorrow it will start making its way
pretty quickly to the east but there
will still be trailing snow ice and
freezing rain that stretch all the way
from the virginias to new england and
then by friday night and early saturday
morning it looks like the system will be
off the east coast but boy it was going
to do a lot of damage in between
especially those icy roads dfw airport
closed right now due to ice and snow
they're de-icing the planes they hope
within an hour they can get a runway
back open sunny skies in southern nevada
today with high pressure but wind will
continue along the colorado river valley
today and the wind advisory has been
extended now until four o'clock in that
area for the river and lakes me to
mohave 53 for us today lighter winds
much lighter than yesterday thank
goodness up to 15 miles an hour
beautiful sunshine to finish the week
and a warming trend that gets us back to
the 60s by the weekend and maybe even
next week we might hit 70 degrees for a
couple of days